MANY MYSTERIES AND SOME NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN THAT CASE.
JUST TWO DAYS AGO A LAWYER
FOR THE LAS VEGAS POLICE
INDICATED NEW CHARGES COULD
BE FORTHCOMING.
ODD.
SINCE THE ONLY SUSPECT IS
DEAD.
DETECTIVES THOUGH SAYING
VERY LITTLE.
CATHERINE LOMBARDO WAS AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING THE
VICTIMS OF LAS VEGAS SHE
JOINS US WITH SCOTT PERRY OF
PENNSYLVANIA WHO SAYS HE HAS
GOT CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THIS
IS GOING.
FIRST TO YOU, CATHERINE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>>
>> YES, WE HAD COURT TWO
DAYS AGO IT WAS THE HEARING
FOR THE PRESS WHERE THEY
ASKED THE COURT TO RELEASE
THE SEARCH WARRANTS AND
AFFIDAVITS AND RETURNS WHICH
MEANS ALL OF THE EVIDENCE,
RIGHT?
SO WHAT WE HEARD WAS QUITE
SHOCKING AND QUITE
SURPRISING.
NOW, YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT SHERIFF LOMBARDO WITH
THE LAS VEGAS METRO POLICE
HAS TOLD US AT HIS BRIEFINGS
THAT STEVEN PADDOCK WAS THE
LONE SHOOTER.
HE WAS THE ONLY SHOOTER.
HOWEVER, AT THE HEARING WE
HEARD TWO THINGS.
ONE, THAT THERE WILL BE NO
INDICTMENTS COMING FOR ANY
MURDER OR SHOOTING; HOWEVER,
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING OTHER
CHARGES AND CRIMES.
THEY WOULDN’T SAY WHO.
THEY WOULDN’T SAY WHAT.
THE ENTIRE COURTROOM TOOK A
GASP AND LOOKED UP AND WENT
SILENT FOR A SECOND.
EVEN THE JUDGE RAWCKETTED
AND THE JUDGE SAID SOMETHING
LIKE OKAY, WITHOUT TELLING
ME WHO OR WHAT, ARE YOU
SAYING TO ME THAT THERE WILL
BE OTHER CHARGES FORTHCOMING
AND THE LAWYER FOR THE
POLICE SAID YES THERE ARE
OTHER CHARGES BEING
INVESTIGATED.
THE JUDGE PRESSED HIM ON
THAT AND HE SAID WITHIN 60
DAYS.
WHAT THE JUDGE DID WAS ASKED
HIM FOR FURTHER SUPPLEMENTAL
BRIEFING TO EXPLAIN TO HER
WHAT THAT CONTAINS, WHO IT
IS, WHAT’S IT’S ABOUT.
YOU SEE, WE’RE ASKING AND
THE PRESS IS ASKING FOR THE
DOCUMENTS, THE EVIDENCE TO
BE RELEASED SINCE THERE IS
NO ONGOING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: THAT WOULD BE
NICE.
ANSWER A BASIC QUESTION SUCH
AS HOW IS I OBJECT TIERIER
DOOR LOCKED INSIDE THE HOTEL
SUITE.
YOU ARE THE ONLY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS I’M AWARE OF TAKEN
A PUBLIC POSITION ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
WHAT ARE YOUR QUESTIONS?
>> WELL, I SMELL A RAT LIKE
A LOT OF AMERICANS DO.
NOTHING IS ADDING UP.
IT’S BEEN FOUR MONTHS.
THE MAN IS DEAD.
THEY SAID IS HE A LONE
SHOOTER YET WE CAN’T GET THE
AUTOPSY RESULTS.
EVEN MORE TROUBLING THAN
THAT, RECENTLY I HAVE BEEN
MADE AWARE OF WHAT I BELIEVE
TO BE CREDIBLE EVIDENCE,
CREDIBLE INFORMATION
REGARDING POTENTIAL
TERRORIST INFILTRATION
THROUGH THE SOUTHERN BORDER
REGARDING THIS INCIDENT.
>> Tucker: TERRORISTS?
>> YES, SIR.
>> Tucker: CONNECTIONS.
WHAT’S THE OUTLINE OF THAT?
>> WELL, THEY COULD BE ISIS
ISIS WARNED THE UNITED
STATES THAT THEY WOULD
ATTACK LAS VEGAS IN JUNE AND
AUGUST AFTER THE ATTACK
CLAIM RESPONSIBILITY FOUR
TIMES.
MEANWHILE THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES ARE TELLING US
THERE IS NO TERRORIST
CONNECTION LONE GUNMAN,
AGAIN, SOMETHING IS NOT
ADDING UP.
>> Tucker: THAT’S PART OF MY
CONFUSION, CATHERINE, CAN
YOU JUST CONFIRM THIS
INVESTIGATION IS STILL BEING
OVERSEEN BY STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES RATHER THAN
FEDERAL?
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
THE FBI AND THE LAS VEGAS
METRO POLICE DEPARTMENT HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTING THE
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF
A TERRORIST ATTACK.
I WILL ASK WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, CONGRESSMAN, UNLESS
HAVE YOU SPECIFIC EVIDENCE
TO BACK THAT UP, IT SEEMS A
BIT IRRESPONSIBLE TO MAKE
THAT ALLEGATION SO, IF YOU
DO, OR MAKE THAT ASSERTION,
IF DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE
OF THAT, I’M ASKING YOU
RIGHT NOW TO SHARE IT WITH
US AND TELL US WHAT THAT IS.
MY CLIENT.
>> I’M NOT ABLE.
>> MY CLIENT, VICTIMS, ALL
22,000 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WAITING AND WAITING AND
WAITING FOR EVIDENCE.
>> Tucker: LET’S LET THE
CONGRESSMAN RESPOND TO THAT.
>> WE HAVE ALL BEEN WAITING.
I’M WAITING, TOO.
LIKE I SAID NOTHING ADDS UP.
I’M TELLING YOU I HAVE
RECEIVED WHAT I FEEL TO BE
AND BELIEVE TO BE CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE OF A POSSIBLE
TERRORIST NEXUS.
>> WHAT IS IT.
>> WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
THAT SITUATION DEVELOPS.
>> Tucker: SLOW DOWN FOR ONE
SECOND.
I’M NOT TAKING A POSITION ON
THIS EITHER WAY.
I WANT TO DIG DOWN A LITTLE
BIT HERE.
IF THAT IS YOUR BELIEF, DOES
CONGRESS HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY
IN THIS.
>> I DON’T KNOW THAT
CONGRESS HAS A ROLE.
I THINK WHO DOES HAVE A ROLE
IS THE NATIONAL COUNTER
TERRORISM CENTER.
AND IF ISIS CLAIMS -- IF
ISIS WARNS ABOUT AN ATTACK
AND AN ATTACK OCCURS AND
CLAIMS RESPONSIBILITY AFTER
THE FACT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME THAT AT A
MINIMUM THEY SHOULD HAVE
SOME PORTION OF THE
INVESTIGATION TO CLEARLY
DEBUNK THAT CLAIM AND, YET,
IT HASN’T HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: SO TOMORROW WE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF
TIME BUT WE WILL BE TAKING A
PRESS CONFERENCE TOMORROW
OUT OF LAS VEGAS BY THE
INVESTIGATORS.